sure it's well inflated these are skills
needed on the front lines in ukraine
being taught in how-to videos by doctors
at mcgill university using mannequins
they go through trauma procedures
step-by-step chest tube insertions
cricothyrodomies and other urgent
medical acts or complex facial
structures before they're translated
into ukrainian
complicated surgeries for less than
ideal situations
the process of simplifying things can be
is very challenging
it needs to be more elegant it needs to
be more on point
ukraine has surgeons but like most
countries they don't have enough
throughout the country and on the front
lines to serve all those in need right
now during a bloody war so the mcgill
doctors targeted medical professionals
medics and doctors who can help save
lives with a bit of rapid refresher
training it's something very personal to
dr nadia demko who has family in ukraine
i think it's actually the driving force
for me is knowing
how how much they're being affected by
it dr tarak lubani knows from personal
experience how critical urgent cares and
supplies can be he was working in the
gaza strip as a medic in 2018 when he
was shot in both legs there weren't
enough tourniquets to go around so he
had to treat and sew up his own wounds
i was very lucky i was
i was shot in areas that don't bleed
very much so i lost blood i lost
probably half a liter now he works with
a group called glia which is raising
money to 3d print as many tourniquets as
they can if they can't get them printed
in ukraine they'll assemble and ship
them from elsewhere in fact we want
other people to make it we just want to
make sure that they make it safely and
they make it in a way so that it's
saving lives everywhere that's what they
all swore to dedicating their careers to
saving lives even from half a world away
anything we can do to to help navigate
this even the smallest degree of support
is is of such great value people on the
front lines in ukraine can certainly use
the help mike droli global news toronto